Hello.
Oh!
Oh my.
Hello.
I am the most unluckiest player in the world.
Listen.
Life hands in lemons.
We're gonna make some lemonade.
We can get this done.
Don't worry.
Hello Dokie.
How are you?
Hello.
I am very tired but hello.
Okay!
Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you as well.
I see you've been doing a little bit of secret training though in the meantime.
Is that correct?
If by secret training you mean playing rank for five hours at degen hours then yeah I I guess... I don't know what I'm doing.
I...
No, that's perfect.
That's how we all start.
But I'm here to make it so you know what you're doing.
Maybe... maybe slightly.
Or maybe we don't want to know.
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
I'm trying to figure out, like, how much you want to know.
Like, how much do you want to open your third eye, versus kind of... just go at it raw.
Like, I'm trying to understand what you're thinking here.
I just... I just don't want to get absolute destroyed.
That's... that's really it.
I just don't want to be the worst player in my division.
As long as I'm better than, like, at least one person, then I'm happy.
You know, if you pick, like, a target, I can try to, like, figure out exactly how you can beat them.
Because the thing is, at your level, in, like, the beginner tier, sometimes being the worst player will make you win the most.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a little...
It's kind of like a weird topsy-turvy land that you're in right now.
So I'm trying to figure out...
how we're going to approach this.
And so I think I need to know a little bit about what you know now.
Well, I just want to do...
And then we can go from there.
I want to...
Well, what I know?
Okay.
That's a very good question.
I don't even know what I know.
I've just been...
Because, like, BrawlPro is, like, secondhand coaching me.
Because I usually play at, like, degen hours.
So, like, starting at, like, 11 p.m., that's when I usually play.
Are you...
And then he was, like...
He's been, like, dropping knowledge down.
Like...
Funneling your knowledge to him.
And then he's been funneling the knowledge to me.
I'm scared of what he's filtering to you.
And then...
He tried to coach me last night.
And, like, I'm just, like...
And then I showed him...
Because he was watching me play ranked.
And then the thing is, in the elo I was in, I was doing the most, like, super bad habit stuff.
Because, like, he was, like, you can't do that again.
So the other...
I mean, so...
But, like, I'm winning, so...
That might not be true.
That's what I'm wondering.
See, I feel like he's trying to set you, like...
There's a difference between giving you the fundamentals that will help you win in the long run versus we need to win tomorrow and you need to abuse the fact that they're all also new.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, yeah.
Like, you can win right now by doing really bad habits that new players will not be able to stop.
Yeah.
And if you're okay with that...
That's how I climbed.
I've just been doing... because I was doing that... what was it?
The back triangle thing where he just runs at you and grabs and then you players don't know what the fuck to do.
So I just kept doing that.
And I got like a seven game win streak by just doing that.
And then obviously the moment I got to bronze, they realized they can jump.
So I was like, okay, now what else can I abuse to climb out of bronze?
No, that's good.
I like the mentality.
Yeah, that running bear grab, it's good.
And we can get a little even trickier with it.
That was one of the things I wrote in that guide to do.
We can get a little bit of... use some normals into it, like your square button into that at certain ranges.
And it's even trickier.
But all we got to do is abuse that.
And then if they're jumping it, then we need to go to the next plan.
So we can keep that as part of the main plan because there's a chance they won't know what to do.
Yeah.
Definitely a chance.
And then it's really funny because like Brawl Pro is on Classic.
So like, because I do like those like every time, because apparently Classic is like super fucking hard for Zangief.
And then he would see me do like the jump triangle.
And he's like, how do you do that?
And I was like, I don't know, let's do buttons.
I just, it's a jump triangle.
So you're doing the, that's the grab, right?
Like you're jumping in the air and grabbing them?
Yeah, like when they jump, I just grab them.
Okay.
And he says like...
Like, it's very hard to do that.
And I was just like, you just jump.
Well, Brawl Pro is just kind of a scrub.
So I mean, I wouldn't, I just wouldn't worry about anything he says.
It's really two buttons for me.
Yeah, don't worry.
Don't worry.
We'll set the record straight.
So anyways, yeah, that's good.
So you understand the concept of anti-airing with that?
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you have any recorded matches actually right now?
Yeah, I mean, well, I have replays, so...
Well, the CFN is down.
Like, you mean replays in the game?
Or do you have like anything?
No, I thought you... you can't access replay when it's maintenance?
Maybe.
Do you want to try?
Yeah, I'll check.
And then you can... maybe... are you... can you share your screen when you do that?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So if I can just see like a game where you're doing things, I can get a feel for what's going on.
All right.
Is it CFN?
Oh, no.
It won't let you?
It just says local replays.
Okay, we'll make do.
So why don't we just have you go to training mode and then share your screen?
Okay.
We'll make do.
So why don't we just have you go to training mode and then share your screen?
Okay.
We'll make do.
So why don't we just have you go to training mode and then share your screen?
And then you can just tell me a bit more about kind of what your... what your favorite moves are.
And we can go from there.
All right.
I'm going to go to training.
I wonder if like Brob... no, I don't think Brob will record any.
He records his own stuff, not me.
Uh, did you have a VOD?
Did you stream any of these matches at any point?
What?
No, I didn't.
I was just screen sharing for him.
Okay.
So yeah, I mean, you got... you understand the command grab and you understand anti-airs.
So...
That's like 70% of the game plan, I feel like.
Did you use DI at all?
That's going to be the L1 button.
The DI.
Wait, what's DI?
Is DI...
Oh, he has this!
Yeah.
Slap.
The red thing, right?
Uh, yes.
Sorry, that's my dog.
He's angry.
That's okay.
What's your dog's name?
Oh, his name is Doki.
But like, I don't call him Doki on stream.
Because that's confusing.
Yeah, that sounds confusing actually.
Okay.
Hello Doki.
So yeah, the L1 is the Armored... the armored move.
Have you tried spamming that a bunch at all?
Like the armored move?
Oh, this?
Yeah, so I'm calling it an armored move Oh, yeah, I rebinded it because I kept... I rebinded that to R1.
Okay.
Oh.
Because I kept accidentally pressing parry instead, so like, I binded parry to L1, because it's pretty away from me.
You swapped them.
Okay.
Yeah, that move, if you haven't thrown it out a bunch, it's definitely really good against newer players, because it can absorb multiple hits.
So if they're trying to punch you a bunch, hit you a bunch, that move can just blow through all their attacks.
And when it does that, it'll do like a big slowdown.
So if you do it right now in training mode and you hit them, it doesn't do the effect, because he's not getting hit out of a move.
But normally, it'll do like this big, super slowdown.
And so that move was really good to press, just kind of like when you guys are feeling each other out, in neutral, like pressing buttons.
Just press that button, if they're pressuring you too much, and you'll probably smack them super hard.
And when it does that, you can press triangle, and you'll be able to combo into your grab.
Oh yeah, I've been doing that in rank.
Yeah.
Okay, so you do know about that.
Yeah, that's good.
It's gonna be super, super common.
And if they're doing that against you, the thing about that move, like the counter it, it's a universal move.
You also press that button in return if they're doing it to you.
So I feel like your opponents, this is gonna be a common strategy, like using DI and countering DI is gonna be the main thing.
So if someone also presses that move against you, you can react to that move in turn.
And then also it'll give you the combo where you can just mash your triangle after.
So getting familiar with that is gonna be really valuable.
So you can spam it against people, and if they're not ready for it, just keep spamming it and then keep pressing triangle.
And if they're spamming it against you, you can also react to it and press it in turn.
So that move is gonna be super valuable, I think.
The coaches will probably tell the other players how to counter that, but it's still worth throwing out.
Yeah.
So what are some of your other favorite moves that you've been messing with?
Well, like I said, usually I just do this to start it off.
And then if they don't counter it, I just keep doing that until they learn how to jump or like, grapple me.
And then when they start throwing it, cause like, the only way, I feel like the only way to stop it, cause I got stuck in throw loops when I kept spamming this at people.
And then Brawl Pro told me, like, all I had to do was throw them back.
So if they start throwing, I just do this to them.
Or like this.
Exactly.
If they throw loop me.
And then if the back triangle doesn't work, I just like, what do I do?
I don't even remember.
I abuse this a lot too.
Especially when they're jumping.
So when they get close to me, they're jumping a lot.
Cause like, because I keep doing this.
So they start jumping a lot.
And then after they start jumping a lot, I just abuse the spinny spin.
And then, and then after that, I don't, after that it's just a wild card.
I mean, sometimes I do this sometimes, sometimes I head butt.
And then if I have a three, then I can do my...
Okay.
So you know about the auto combo?
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
I mean, I mean what you mentioned right there, that's a very structured game plan already, right?
Like the, the down triangle, his lariat, that stops people out of the air.
You're going for grabs, which they have to jump.
And then if they go in the air, you do that.
So yeah, that makes, that's a solid game plan already.
Do you find yourself like mashing a lot?
Like, are you in that phase where you're kinda like panicking and sometimes you just start mashing random buttons?
Does that happen?
Well, I used to, and then I realized this game does not do mashing very well, and I was like, oh man, you actually have to think.
You actually have to think in this game so I can't actually mash my buttons.
It's debatable but, yeah sometimes.
Cause every time I try to mash my buttons like, I can't do anything, even in bronze, So, I was like, okay, I'll just abuse moves that I actually know.
So, I try not to mash for this game just because I feel like it's more detrimental than it is helping me.
Yeah, that's kind of true for most situations.
I will say the one thing I would encourage you to mash if people are doing a bit too much pressure on you.
Besides the DI, which I mentioned, you should throw that out every once in a while.
It would also be your square button while crouching.
So, that move is good to stop people from walking you down and from constantly approaching you.
That's going to be one of your fastest buttons.
And if people are pressing buttons and walking up and doing more things or running at you, that's going to be the button that you say, hey, we'll slow down a little bit.
And then you can at least go back to some kind of control.
And you see what it does.
As moves hit like that, you did like three of the squares or two or three depending on how close you are.
And then it pushes you too far away.
That's a common concept in this game.
Like if people do too many attacks in a row, it pushes you away.
And so, a good thing to understand is like what you can do at that range.
So, if you check them with the three squares and then it pushes to that range, then what's the next thing you can do?
And I think the next thing for you to do is going to be your head...
Oh, whoa.
Yeah, that's an option.
Okay.
That's an option.
I was going to say press heavy punch, but you have dry brush SPD.
Yeah.
Like usually I just do that on repeat too.
That's good.
I kept doing that, but it'll hit.
Okay.
Until they learn to jump.
And then after they learn to jump, I just do this.
Right.
No, that's perfect.
Perfect.
So, one other option to mix in there, which will be...
It'll help make the dry brush triangle, the big grab.
It'll make that more effective is if you're at that range, like after the three squares, press heavy, which is the big punch.
And you can tap that or charge it because it has armor if you charge it.
So, that's another move to like say, hey, stop moving, stop doing things.
Right?
So, that move will make them a little bit scared to move and do any actions.
Yeah.
And when they're scared to move...
Like that one.
Perfect.
When they're scared to move, that's when that dry brush command grab that you did, the dry brush triangle, that's when that becomes super good because they're like, oh crap, I got a block.
Then you just dry brush in and grab them.
Okay.
So, mixing after those three jabs, mix between heavy punch or the...
Oh, sorry.
Mix between X or your dry brush triangle.
That's a...
Okay.
You got a mix up right there.
That's a mix up.
Yeah.
They're guessing between two options right away.
Sweet.
Do you jump at your opponents at all?
No.
Do you ever use any jumping attacks?
Oh, I mean, if they fucking high duking, yeah.
Okay.
If they start high duking and then after that, I just...
Oh, wait.
After that, I start doing this.
Yeah.
That one's good.
If I get closer enough.
But like...
From further away, you want to use the jump square.
That's going to be your best jump in from further away.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Jump X.
My bad.
Oh, jump X.
I'm trying to translate for myself.
I'm looking at my controller here to read the place.
To jump away?
That would be the jump at them.
Oh, jump at them.
Okay.
So that...
From a further distance, press the button a little later.
Yeah.
The big boot.
It hits pretty low.
So, if you're like there, that perfect jump distance, that's when you use jump X.
So, you wait till you get close enough.
Perfect.
And you can do that.
But when you're really close, this is one thing I think you can spam.
So, like walk into Jamie's face here.
Like walk into your opponent's face.
And then you're going to do a jump forward.
And then you're going to do the splash.
The down plus heavy.
Or down plus...
What button is it?
Down plus X.
No.
Down plus circle.
Sorry.
I'm trying to remember these controls.
Yeah.
Okay.
This?
No.
While you're in the air, that moves.
Oh, the splash.
Oh, this one.
Okay.
So, walk all the way up into his grill.
Like get all on his face and then do it.
And then press the jump in a little later.
Press the down plus circle.
Yeah.
See how you landed on the other side?
You can keep doing that back and forth on either side over and over.
And it's going to change the way they have to block.
So, yeah.
You got to do it a little later.
Do the attack a tiny bit later.
Okay.
And then do it the other side.
I guarantee you.
If you just kind of throw this out, because it's a cross up, meaning they have to block a different direction, it's going to overwhelm people really, really hard.
And you can keep spamming that over and over.
And then when you want to mix it up, you can stay on the ground for a second and then press triangle.
Okay.
I guarantee you there's going to be players who are just going to lose to that over and over.
Because it's really hard for them to hit you out of the air.
So, they might have a move that can stop you.
If they stop you, sure, slow down.
Okay.
Yeah, that I think might be super good cheese.
And then eventually they'll be scared and they'll just sit there.
And then you can press your triangle.
Because the whole gameplay with Gief is you want to just scare them from moving so that you can press triangle and grab them and do a ton of damage.
Yeah.
That's his whole mentality.
So, we're trying to figure out the best way to make that happen.
Okay.
BrawlPro says we did this last night.
You forgot?
I don't remember like 60% of the stuff he told me.
It's a lot.
I mean, it's like drinking from a fire hose.
He's trying to teach me some combos.
I don't even remember the combo.
I think it was like...
What was it?
What was the combo he was trying to teach me?
I don't know.
Who cares?
That's what I was worried.
When I saw he was teaching, I'm like, he's going to be trying to teach you some hard shit.
Like, you got to understand the vibe here.
It's got to be...
We're keeping it simple.
Oh, I remember.
It was like...
Okay.
It was like splash and then this and then this.
Yeah.
Too much.
My brain fried.
Yeah.
You already know the combo you want to do.
So the only combos you should worry about are holding the auto combo button and mashing circle or X.
And you can do that when you're closer to the opponent.
Yeah.
So you can do it there and just hold it and mash and yeah.
I wouldn't worry about doing any classic combos.
The one with X, I think it's pretty good because it hits from further away.
So you don't have to do it from the...
You don't have to do it from a jump in.
So you can kind of be out of your command grab range, like your triangle range.
And then just hold auto combo and mash X.
Yeah.
If it hits, this big super will come out if you have the meter.
And if it doesn't hit, you'll just get the lariat.
And that's technical.
It's technically unsafe, but I don't think your opponents are going to punish you.
And the other button at that range is just X without auto combo.
He does the chop and that, yeah, you can mash that.
So that has really good range actually.
So that's another option, like after your three square range, like, you know, you mash square three times and it pushes you away.
That's another great option from at that spacing.
Yeah.
So that's one of his best pokes.
So your main strategy, you know, you can do the crouching square standing X.
Those are going to be your main like buttons that you're going to poke with and then stand X as well.
Oh, stand X.
Okay.
Yeah.
Those are going to be your main pokes at that range.
And then other than that, mix in what you know, like the, the running bear grab, throw that in randomly.
Once you kind of scare them or that's the back triangle.
Yay.
And then mix in the jump splash when you're closer and then mixing the grab.
And I think really that's, let's keep it simple, right?
Let's let's keep a few options and rotate between them.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I like simple.
I only know five moves in Tekken and that's all I need.
Yeah.
Let's let's not overwhelm anything.
I mean, if there's something else you want to worry about, the only other thing along with this is the DI.
Just throw that out every once in a while.
Yeah.
And let's here, let's, let's test the combo that I just want to see you do the combo.
Can you pause the training mode and I want to put on a setting real quick.
So let's go to dummy settings, like the big menus.
Yeah.
And then on a counter, we're going to put it on punish counter.
So just keep clicking that always punish counter.
Okay.
And then on block, what's changed that setting to block after first hit.
So just keep scrolling.
There.
Perfect.
So now we can back out of the menu.
Okay.
And then now let's try a DI.
So it should do the big slowdown now.
See and now you match the triangle.
Perfect.
You got the combo.
There you go.
Look how much damage you did.
Perfect.
Yeah.
This carried me all the way to bronze four.
Let's go.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Then you know it.
If you can do this combo, you got your best combo right here.
I think you're set.
Yay.
Hell yeah.
Is there anything else you're curious about or thinking about right now?
Um, how do I, how do I play against Blanka?
Okay.
That one's going to be hard.
Cause Blanka has full screen lunging.
Yeah.
I wish I had training mode with you right now.
That's that's going to be the hardest thing.
So, um, against Blanka pairing is good.
I don't want to overwhelm you with that, but like, you know, your drive rush and the Perry.
Yeah.
They kind of, they work together.
Right.
Cause you have to be in Perry to then cancel to the dry brush.
When Blanka is going to fly at you, you want to hold the Perry, not tap it, like press it.
If I hold it, you'll absorb him when he flies at you.
And then after that, you're going to dash to do your drive rush to run at him.
Okay.
So, and then.
Right.
Cause the whole thing is, um, the Blanka player is going to keep spamming.
They're called Blanka balls.
They're going to spam that, which is a full screen lunging move to try to hit you from full screen.
And then you need to approach.
So that's going to be a big part of the game plan is absorbing that and then running at them.
Okay.
So, uh, chat says Lariat beats Blanka ball.
Hmm.
I don't know.
We'll have, we'd have to test that.
I try that, but sometimes it does like, sometimes they hit me before I hit them.
Yeah.
Cause Lariat's very slow is the problem.
It's like very 50 50.
Yeah.
It's worth trying, but if it's not working out, the safest thing to do is like to Perry and then you can try dry brushing in or just Perry and then walk in and then kind of work your way in.
Um.
Okay.
Yeah.
Maybe we can, uh, practice that tomorrow or something.
We have time.
Cause that's going to be the trickiest kind of cheese to get around.
We got to get familiar with that.
Yeah.
Perry's going to be your, your best option against the blockable from distance.
Cause the problem is if you block in this game for too long, you lose your meter.
So you can't really block it forever either.
Even, even if you're being very patient.
Okay.
Uh, stand heavy punch.
Yeah.
That might be an option.
And sometimes I do this a lot too.
That's good.
Yeah, it covers a lot of distance.
Like if you do it from far away.
Like this usually is my like... like if I'm desperate and I want them to... and it's like they're like almost one HP.
One thing that's really good is if you land your grab, like if you start from like the middle of the screen, like restart training mode and land your grab.
After you land your grab, you can walk forward like just a little tiny bit and then do that move and it'll hit them.
So it's a way to like keep your pressure going.
So if you test it here, like do the triangle move on him.
Okay.
And then...
And then just walk forward a tiny bit.
A tiny bit and do that move.
Even less than that.
You can do it even less.
Like a tighter walk.
It'll keep them like pinned down basically.
It'll keep the pressure going.
Pretty good.
You can do it even less.
Like I'm talking like a tiny, tiny walk.
But that was the idea.
You got it.
Like that's a good way to... because the problem with this move is that it does a bunch of damage.
But see how far away it leaves you.
You know, keep his best up close.
So definitely you can mix in that move after the grab.
Like a little walk forward and do it and get in.
And once again, that scares them to block.
And when they're scared to block, that's when you can use your drive rush to get in.
Okay.
Oh, not that.
Uh...
BrawlPro says you were doing drive rush after SPDs last night.
Yeah, that's good.
Yeah, definitely do a lot of drive rush after SPD.
Yeah.
Do you ever do drive rush into the down circle?
Like that's his sweep where he kicks the ground.
Oh, he said this move sucks.
Yeah, sorry.
Not that one.
This one?
Down forward circle.
Oh, this one.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely don't do down circle.
That move does suck.
Yeah.
He said this move fucking sucks.
Yeah, it actually does suck.
Yeah, I do this sometimes.
Yeah, because you can also...
When I'm on the left side, when I'm on the other side, I forget how to do it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that happens.
Yeah, there's a lot of side swapping in Street Fighter.
It takes a while to remember each side.
Yeah, if you can land the triangle, you can drive rush and then do that move when you're close enough.
That'll body a lot of people.
Or just throw that out.
Like that down forward circle.
It has such good range.
A lot of players will walk into it and get hit.
Doki's a left side player and this is good.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I just...
I'll try this in rank.
Yeah, you'll beat some people.
And once they stop it...
Oh, I don't know.
D-Gen hours was fucking crazy.
Like, Bra Pro was watching me fight some crazy bronze players.
I mean, you're in no man's land right now.
That's why I'm trying to make you as degenerate as they are.
Like, it's such a long journey to get out of there and play anything resembling, like, classy Street Fighter.
That I think just fighting dirty is the best strategy right now.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
I can't do this.
Oh.
Pressing the wrong button.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yay.
Yeah.
Strats.
And then when they're scared, just triangle.
Woo!
Okay.
Perfect.
Anything else you're thinking of?
Anything else you can remember from your games that was giving you trouble?
Bra Pro.
Do you remember?
I don't remember.
It was, like, four in the morning.
All right.
Do we got notes?
Bra Pro?
Bra Pro.
You know more.
Sounds like he was giving you, like, really hard homework.
I don't know.
Too much.
She dies a lot after she gets knocked down and they keep hitting her.
Okay.
Because they put me in the corner and I get scared.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that might be where you're on wake up.
Is she getting counter hit a lot?
That's what I was asking.
Like, do you find yourself mashing?
Oh, I don't block.
Okay.
So you're pressing buttons.
I don't block.
You keep telling me to do this.
Yeah.
Do that.
If you're going to mash, here's the thing.
If you're going to mash, the only discipline I want you to have is mash your square while holding that position.
If you're going to mash, at least make it this.
Right?
Okay.
Until you build some space.
Like, that's the one thing I will do.
That's what I will say because you're going to mash.
You're going to get scared and you're going to start mashing.
If you can at least try to make it that move, then that's good.
Okay.
Oh, actually, the one final thing to mash.
Do you know how to do your level three?
Oh, yeah.
Mash that.
If you got knocked down and they're approaching you, I mean, you lost your meter, but if you have that meter, 100% mash that.
Those are the two things I'm telling you to mash.
Okay.
Now, if you can try to keep it to those two, it's going to be hard, but those are the two things that you should try to mash.
Yeah.
And once you build the space, then, you know, try to stop mashing.
The idea is, like, if they leave a gap in their pressure, because they will because their pressure is bad, you will tag them with the little pokes and build some space and have some breathing room.
Have her play computer.
Oh, we can try that.
Yeah.
Why don't we try just having you play the computer for a little bit?
Put the CPU on, like, level three or something.
So, no, I think you can do it here, actually.
Can you do it in training?
Oh.
I think you can do it versus also.
Versus?
You can do both.
Yeah.
We can go to versus.
Make CPU Blanca.
We can try that.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Okay.
You're good.
So, next.
And then, yeah, that's good.
And then, yeah, we can try Blanca.
And then CPU level, let's put on that, like, three.
Yeah, let's try three.
Okay.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I don't know what he's going to do.
You think CPU has eyes?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Sometimes they read your soul.
That's the problem.
I don't want you to turn up the level too high.
Do you think they read my soul?
Yeah.
Sometimes they read your soul.
Sometimes.
Okay.
Then I'll just do this.
I don't think the CPU has eyes.
I don't...
We are going to win this shit.
We're so ready.
Let's go.
Set it higher.
Yeah, we might need to level up the CPU.
I don't...
Yeah, I don't think the CPU...
The CPU is learning.
This is beautiful.
You might just win like this.
Okay.
Let's crank up the CPU a little bit.
Select character, I think.
Okay.
Hell yeah.
That was sick, though.
Let's try five.
Let's see.
If you go like...
I don't know.
Seven, eight.
It's actually crazy.
CPU is unfair at that level.
Nice.
Oh, he backed out.
Okay.
It begins.
Oh, my God.
He's doing stuff now.
What is that?
It's like an assist thing.
Okay.
He's doing a bunch of his commands.
Man grab.
That jump move is his version of the running bear grab that you're doing.
Yeah.
You have to jump it just like you would have to jump your own grab.
What if I don't?
What if I just grab him back?
That works, too.
If you grab him before he grabs you, then no complaints from me.
Oh.
There you go.
Oh, I did it, too.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, man.
That's the idea.
Even the CPU can't handle it.
Oh, no.
You're good.
Just block.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
I just grabbed him.
Okay.
Oh.
That's not bad.
Okay.
In this mode, he's going to do a bunch of those flying Blanka balls.
Nice.
Very good.
And the next time you land that, you can mash your level three instead.
Because you'll just kill him if you land that again.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's the grab.
No.
Okay.
That worked.
We got to go up another level.
Okay.
The CPU does not comprehend the techniques you're throwing at him.
Let's see.
Let's see if it understands what an SPD is at this level.
Yeah.
This is looking good.
Oh.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Nice.
No.
He jumps.
How could you?
Yeah.
He's grabbing you back now.
Oh.
And he's not letting me grab, too.
Whoa.
Yeah.
This is when the CPU starts cheating.
That's not fair.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, damn.
Oh.
That's fine.
You can tank that.
You got the health for it.
Oh.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
That was nice.
I like the squares thrown in there.
Very good.
That was a great time to use that.
Hell yeah.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
He jumps a lot.
Oh.
I just timed it.
Nice.
No.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Okay.
I like that you used the auto combo there.
That was good.
Yeah.
The only thing I would say is let's try to use the Lariat a little bit less.
Like, you were using the Lariat when he was in the corner.
Okay.
But you saw it wasn't working and then you swapped to the heavy auto combo.
Yeah.
That was brilliant.
That was a perfect time to use that heavy auto combo.
Yeah.
That was perfect.
Okay.
Yeah.
The CPUs are kind of a little dumb about Zangief, though.
Like, it doesn't really understand the command grabs.
Oh, 7 might be.
Let's see.
It's about to get serious.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Maybe 8.
No.
Let's see.
I want to see what happens.
I thought that was the pattern we were trying to do.
No, no.
Let's go.
Let's see what happens.
Okay.
Let's see.
I think they actually have combos at level 7.
All right.
Whoa.
He's going to be crazy.
He may be.
If you beat level 7, level 8 CPU, that's going to be insane.
Yeah.
Nice heavies.
Oh, no.
Time for the square.
Time for mashing square.
Yeah.
Perfect.
See?
See how that backed him away?
That was good.
Leave me alone!
Nice.
Leave me alone.
Nice combo.
Hell yeah.
Oh, shit.
That's not what I wanted, actually.
Oh, that's not what I wanted.
Okay.
Good read.
Countering the DI with Lariat.
That was so sick!
Oh my god!
It's crazy that you have the SPD anti-airs.
Okay.
No, but you saw the situation and you capitalized on it.
The awareness is crazy right now.
Oh, that was a good idea.
Yeah, that was a good idea.
I was just a little late.
No, please!
Not the Q&A!
Time for Square!
Yes!
Perfect!
Not the Q&A!
Time for Square!
No!
He's gonna do the thing!
Yeah, that was a tough situation.
Nice.
They got combos now.
Oh, guys.
He actually knows combos.
Yeah, they start leveling up quick.
Oh, he has his little assistant chasing you.
Okay.
Alright, time for Square.
Not the Q&A!
Oh!
Let's go!
That's the other one!
Even better!
Let's go!
Okay.
You're gonna need, like, one more grab.
No!
Oh, Goodberry!
Oh!
Triangle!
Yes!
Oh, my God!
Yay!
I'm alive!
I can't... I honestly am so impressed that you just beat the CPU at level 7.
You're at level 8.
Let's see it.
Let's see.
I gotta see it.
This is insane.
No, I'm gonna get ranked!
You know what you're doing!
I'm gonna get destroyed!
No, you know what you're doing!
Let's see it.
Fuck!
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He's actually blocking, too.
Oh, does he get it?
No, he gets it.
Yeah, he counters the ice now.
Yeah.
Please.
Please, let me be alive.
Oh, he's throwing out BlankaChan.
Wait, does... CPU BlankaChan has mixups?
Good squares.
Good squares, though.
Don't leave me alone in the square!
See?
Good squares.
The squares are good, though.
Oh.
I thought I could get the anti.
What the fuck?!
Oh, he did Perfect Variance and countered DI to level 2 activation.
What the fuck do I do?!
He's gotta style it on you.
What do I do?!
Good square.
Get out of here.
See?
You're building space.
Nice.
Now you can get out.
Fucking hell.
Nice.
No, that's not what I wanted.
Whoops.
Okay.
You're in.
No!
Good idea, though.
Get me out of here!
That was a good idea.
Okay.
Level 8 CPU is kind of a different beast.
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go.
Run it back.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh.
Maybe he...
Oh, he jumps, too!
Yeah.
CA would have killed.
Mashing CA there would have been good.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
Leave me alone, please.
He might force you to block a little bit on wake up.
I know we didn't talk about that plan, but...
Please.
You might have to.
I'm scared.
I think what you gotta do is when he's approaching you, you gotta press your circle, the heavy punch, and, like, hold it a little to get the armor.
Yeah.
Okay.
You need that armor to, like, stop him from...
Yeah.
Perfect.
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
He is godlike.
I'm sorry.
What is he doing?
Oh, my God.
He's ready.
Bro, this guy...
What is his rank?
This is beyond master.
This is, like, at least 1800 MR.
Minimum.
Yeah.
This guy's kinda nice.
He wins.
Yeah.
Level 8 is, like, when they start cheating, kinda.
I know my place.
Yeah.
Level 7 is a good one to practice.
Level 8, they really start kinda cheating.
Like, it's just unfair.
The reactions are inhuman.
But that's... your game plan is good.
The only thing I would say is try using that circle, the heavy punch, a little bit more at a distance.
Yeah.
Because that move with armor is super buff.
Like, people will just mash into it.
But I like everything else you're doing.
I have no complaints.
Nice.
I think you're killing it.
That's all I need to know.
As long as I beat one person during the slam, I'm happy.
Yeah.
And I think if we have another chance to sync up when this is online, we can try going over the Blanka-specific stuff.
Because I'm sure they're gonna tell Gumi, right?
Yeah.
She's gonna sit there and do Blanka Ball over and over.
But we just need to have, like, one counter to that.
I'll figure out what the perfect counter is, and then we can cover that.
And I think you can style on her.
Go ahead.
It'll be sick.
Nice.
That's all I need to know.
Sweet.
Okay.
Anything else for now, then?
Any other last questions or anything?
No, I think that's... I think I'm good.
That's all I need.
I think.
I hope.
Awesome.
And then, I guess, like, tomorrow when Rink is back online, we can have, like...
I guess, like...
a better coaching session with, like, actual players.
Yeah.
Are you gonna be available in non-D-Gen hours tomorrow?
What's going on?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I'll be available.
Yeah, I'll be available during the day tomorrow.
I'm gonna try to get on and see if you want some coaching and practice.
So that's my plan tomorrow.
Okay.
Sweet.
All right.
Hell yeah.
Well, nice meeting you, Doki.
I don't know if you're coaching anybody else, but, like, good luck with the rest of your day.
Same to you.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Great meeting you.
Nice meeting you as well.
Finally the first coaching session.
Yes.
It went very well.
I'm very impressed.
Yay!
All right.
Take care.
Till next time.
All right.
Bye.
Okay.
There we go.
Good session.
She knows what she's doing.
Listen, BrawlPro, you in this chat right now?
Stop whatever poison you're putting into Doki's mind.
She's ready.
Try to teach her combos and shit?
Come on, bro.
You got to do the headbutt into the Hellstab into the Lariat?
No, dude.
You got to remember who she's fighting.
All we got to figure out is Blanka Ball.
That's about it.
Like, what's the easiest and most consistent way to deal with Blanka Ball?